Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de Franz 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
España tiene 13 los territorios más
despoblados del sur de Europa estas
zonas son Rurales y se han visto
afectadas de manera desproporcionada por
la migración hacia la ciudades los
municipios Rurales abarcan el 84% del
territorio sin embargo menos del 16% de
la población reside en él de acuerdo a
datos del año 2021 en este reporteros
viajaremos a algunos de estos lugares
que en los últimos 50 años perdieron más
de un 22% de la población una
despoblación que impacta no solo a la
economía sino a la calidad de vida de
quienes deciden quedarse que ven como
los servicios públicos y la
infraestructura van desapareciendo de
sus territorios
Marina Colorado quien con William
González realizó este reportaje se
encuentra hoy con nosotros Hola Marina
comienzo preguntándole en el país se ha
extendido la expresión de la España
vacía para referirse a estas zonas que
como decíamos abarcan buena parte de la
superficie nacional sin embargo esta
expresión no gusta a quienes habitan la
España rural porque
Pues porque realmente no está vacía
simplemente está despoblada el adjetivo
vacío tiene connotaciones negativas que
se alejan O sea que para nada tienen que
ver con la realidad que vivimos durante
esos días de grabación del reportaje por
distintas áreas de la España despoblada
son áreas llenas de cultura de
tradiciones de costumbres de gastronomía
y sobre todo de paisajes y de recursos
naturales que literalmente nutren al
resto del país porque ahí es donde se
cultivan las legumbres las frutas y las
verduras que nos alimentan en las
grandes ciudades sin embargo mientras
que las oportunidades de trabajo se
sigan concentrando en los entornos
urbanos y en las ciudades y obviamente
mientras a medida que esos servicios
públicos y que esos servicios básicos
vayan desapareciendo de las zonas
Rurales Pues es normal que la tienda a
migrar hacia esas zonas donde hay más
oportunidades laborales de hecho así lo
confirman las últimas cifras del censo
del Instituto Nacional de estadística de
España en el que dicen que mientras que
la población española ha aumentado en
500.000 habitantes es decir medio millón
de habitantes en la última década 7 de
cada 10 municipios pierden población
esto es porque tendemos a concentrarnos
en los grandes núcleos urbanos Y esto no
es una tendencia que se de solo en
España sino que en todo el mundo es algo
que se repite y tendemos siempre a irnos
a vivir a los grandes núcleos urbanos o
ciudades dejando más despobladas cada
vez las zonas Rurales y más apartadas
veamos la historia
[Música]
amanece en Laguna del marquesado en la
provincia de Cuenca uno de los pueblos
en el epicentro de la llamada laponia
española Región donde la densidad de
población no llega a los dos habitantes
por kilómetro cuadrado
un panorama desértico que viven muchos
de los municipios del interior de España
el 48% de la superficie del país está en
riesgo de despoblación vamos a la plaza
del pueblo y ya como podéis comprobar
quedamos tan claros que no se ve ni
perros ni gatos no hay nadie en el
pueblo Santiago es el alcalde de Laguna
Aunque hay censadas unas 50 personas
menos de 30 viven aquí todo el año
aquí tenemos el único el único jubilado
guardián de la plaza que nos está
cuidando Ángel González tete está
esperando al médico que solo viene con
cita previa
Aquí no hay centro de salud ni escuela
ni tiendas yo tengo 40 años bueno 38 y
lo único que ha sido se ha ido gente de
los pueblos o sea venir no ha venido
nadie y el que ha venido aprobado y no
se ha podido quedar en el pueblo porque
no le gusta porque por trabajo por
familia por pero que al pueblo no viene
nadie hace décadas la vida en el pueblo
era muy distinta la laguna de benigno y
Florencia de 94 y 93 años tenía más de
100 habitantes
la pérdida de servicios básicos les
obligó a irse a Barcelona donde viven
nueve meses al año
farmacia todo tienes que ir a los que si
vienen a vender y si no a cañete tenemos
que ir a comprar un pueblo a 20 km de
distancia y sin transporte público
un matrimonio joven va a tener un niño
ni el colegio ni hay nada
Ale nos vamos además de su función de
alcalde de Laguna del marquesado
Santiago es pastor y ganadero en
extensivo una de las pocas profesiones
que se pueden desarrollar en estos
pueblos pero que cada vez es menos
rentable
este pastor de ovejas siente que la vida
en los pueblos está en declive Y aunque
a él le gusta vivir aquí no se imagina a
sus dos hijos siguiendo sus pasos Pues
que sean infeliz que vivan donde quieran
y que tengan el trabajo que quieran pero
que no los veo viviendo en la laguna no
lo veo
Ven aquí ven gente El Éxodo del campo a
la ciudad en España no es un fenómeno
reciente lleva sucediendo desde la
década de los 60 el resultado es que el
90% de la población vive en el 30% del
territorio
un territorio que se siente olvidado por
la política nacional a nivel de
infraestructuras telecomunicaciones o
servicios básicos
para exigir que se solventen estas
carencias surgió hace 23 años el
movimiento ciudadano teruel existe que
desde 2019 tiene representación en ambas
cámaras del parlamento de España junto
con Cuenca teruel es otra de las
provincias más despobladas del país
Beatriz Martínez senadora por la
agrupación vive en bueña donde quedan
menos de 50 personas pero tal y como
dice el lema de la organización ser
pocos no resta derechos que se han
valorados y que se piense en ellos con
unos servicios básicos
indispensables Y eso Será luego lo que
haga que la gente quiera seguir viniendo
aquí a ver es un proceso muy a largo
plazo estamos hablando que llevamos más
de 40 años con el proceso contrario pues
cuestión de pedagogía de que la gente
entienda esas diferencias que no es una
lucha entre urbano y rural
Beatriz reparte su oficina entre el
senado en Madrid a casi 300 km donde va
cada dos semanas y el dormitorio de un
apartamento familiar en Monreal del
campo a 26 km de su casa yo
principalmente me he puesto aquí para
trabajar porque aquí tengo banda ancha
en mi pueblo tengo
wemax o cobertura por radio y cuando hay
una tormenta o cuando hay aire o sucede
algún día así un poco raro no te puedes
se estropea
al igual que en muchos otros municipios
de la España rural en bueña el bar tuvo
que cerrar porque no había quien se
hiciera cargo Hola qué tal
la alcaldía decidió ofrecer alojamiento
gratuito a alguna familia que quisiera
tomar el negocio
tú me ayudas a servir los platos Alexis
y su mujer llevaban tiempo queriendo
cambiar de estilo de vida y dejar Madrid
seis meses después él andreína y sus
tres hijas son una familia más del
pueblo y alegres por la decisión que
tomamos y ver cómo nuestras hijas se
desenvuelven aquí que pueden estar
libres corriendo cosa que no hacían allá
donde vivíamos Pues eso nos llena
bastante de tranquilidad tras salir de
su Venezuela natal Hace seis años dejar
Madrid atrás no les ha supuesto ningún
esfuerzo algunos extrañaba decía este
que viene de la ciudad ya tiene
animalito
y así Bueno yo me entretengo aquí me
quedo un rato aquí
dándole la comida a los animales
y poco más así y los huevitos para la
tortilla Qué bueno un poco diferente
todo Sabes porque uno lo ve así aquí uno
puede respirar aire sabes ahí en Madrid
es que
hasta la contaminación la contaminación
te vuelve loco sabes Precisamente en
Madrid es donde se concentran casi todos
los organismos estatales para revertir
esta tendencia concentrar todo en la
capital el gobierno de Pedro Sánchez ha
impulsado un plan de reparto de
instituciones en otras ciudades para así
atraer talento y fijar población en
zonas más despobladas
España ha sido Pues históricamente un
país que se ha construido de una forma
muy radial no
maderitas y un centro muy potente sucede
en otros países de Europa o sea hay un
centro muy potente a partir del cual se
establecen la radialidades no el
gobierno lo que pretende es romper ese
principio es decir construir un país
mucho más en Red mucho más mallado y por
tanto de alguna manera también más
eficiente y con más oportunidades en el
conjunto de la geografía del país
de Madrid es Pilar durante pero hace
siete años que vive en la ciudad de
Cuenca de donde es su marido Miguel
Ángel eso está genial admirando a los
dos son ingenieros de Montes Aunque la
descentralización puede crear empleos
que impulsen las economías locales de
zonas despobladas ambos ingenieros
afirman que el campo ya es fuente de
riqueza una riqueza menos tangible e
infravalorada que tiene que haber algún
tipo de compensación con respecto a
todas estas zonas Rurales que al final
no se les habla que son donantes de vida
sin embargo
normalmente las políticas no se les
tiene en cuenta a la hora de gestionarlo
de una forma sostenible y que no sea
ligado a una economía y a lo mejor no
tenga en cuenta la conservación de los
recursos en nuestra casa abrimos el
Grifo y no sabemos De dónde viene ese
agua pero ese agua está ahí porque
existen estas zonas naturales de todo
eso no nos damos cuenta lo que lo que
cuesta o lo que vale Y eso Quizás sí se
puede si es tangible y se podría
monetizar
además de su vínculo familiar cuenca era
un destino lógico para desarrollar su
profesión es la ciudad con la mayor
superficie forestal de la Unión Europea
53.000 hectáreas de bosques la cubren
es en estos bosques donde Pedro y Luis
desarrollan su emprendimiento de gestión
forestal sacando todos los diámetros a
1:30 de todos los árboles que estamos
viendo todas las alturas lo que antes se
hacía árbol árbol estoy escaneando y
midiendo todos a la vez la unión del
mundo tecnológico y rural es una de las
claves para estos jóvenes ingenieros
forestales nacidos en dos provincias
colindantes que en los últimos 10 años
han perdido entre el 5 y el 10% de su
población
mejorando el conteo de las existencias
vas a mejorar la gestión porque vas a
tener un mayor conocimiento de lo que
tienes y eso contribuye a revalorizar
por ejemplo la madera que la gente coja
más interés en gestionar su Monte
beneficio económico y sobre todo ligado
a fijar población en el medio rural que
al final es el objetivo de cualquier
ingeniero forestal agrícola relacionado
con el medio ambiente vaya según ellos
esta tecnología que escanea la
superficie y relieve de los terrenos es
además clave en la lucha contra
incendios podemos elaborar unos mapas
de dependientes y también de combustible
vegetal y gracias a esos mapas se puede
actuar y prevenir una prevención que fue
insuficiente en Zamora la provincia
española más afectada por el fuego en
cuatro personas muertas y casi 69.000
hectáreas de la Sierra de la culebra
calcinadas en dos incendios separados
había un frente de 40 kilómetros o 50
kilómetros era Era algo tremendo un
infierno Julio Fernández es voluntario
de la organización ambiental ecologistas
en acción y ve muy clara la relación
entre el fuego y la pérdida de población
y aquí pues políticamente y
electoralmente no interesa porque casi
no vive nadie entonces pues creo que la
desidia es uno de los factores que hizo
que que todo el fuego se propagara de
esa manera tan Veloz
porque no había interés en Apagar
Hola Mira estáis aquí vigilando en esta
Porque leí el otro día que terminaba la
época de incendios termina la campaña el
30 de septiembre
Cayetana está en su quinta campaña como
escucha de incendios así se les llama a
quienes vigilan lo que ocurre En los
montes
sacayo Sin novedad Hasta luego un
trabajo de temporada que dura solo tres
meses Julio agosto y septiembre por eso
cuando el primer incendio inició el 15
de junio en plena ola de calor y con
sequía generalizada solo el 20% de la
plantilla estaba activa y el no haber
tenido a la gente convocada con tiempo
de antelación cuando tú tienes la
información
meteorológica de lo que está sucediendo
es una negligencia grave y que tiene
consecuencias muy graves una de las
razones detrás de la voracidad del fuego
es que el bosque primario fue sustituido
A mediados del siglo XX por plantaciones
de pinos que con su resina y sus piñas
son El combustible perfecto que al fin y
al cabo esto es una industria esto es
una industria de producción de madera no
es un bosque eso es lo que lo primero
que tenemos que entender y todo eso
requiere una gestión y requiere también
población requiere gente que venga aquí
a vivir y que cuide naturaleza en la
Sierra de la culebra el verde de los
Robles y Las Encinas ha pasado a ser
marrón y negro
y el fuego se lo arrasó todo en 10
minutos Además porque fue de una manera
asesina y cruel
dónde vamos el cabrero como se llama a
sí mismo Santiago León lamenta con rabia
que no hay nada que enseñar y mucho que
llorar es la primera vez que subo desde
el incendio aquí la primera vez
la tierra que era el pasto para sus
cabras ha sido pasto de las llamas
el fuego mató a un tercio del rebaño
familiar y ha dejado secuelas tanto en
los animales como en los ganaderos
secuelas físicas y psicológicas
nosotros tenemos que ser de otra pasta
No porque nadie se ha preocupado
de los niveles o sea de la Salud Mental
de las personas que han sido afectados
por una verdadera tragedia
o sea está tan deshumanizada
esta clase política que traían llegado
O sea mis hijos
hoy se sienten huérfanos
una orfandad que va más allá del impacto
de los incendios y más allá de la Sierra
de la culebra es la ausencia de una
sociedad que atienda y entienda las
necesidades y fortalezas de esta España
rural
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]